صمود المشاهدين غير متوقعه للقوات
الاوكرانيه لاثني عشر شهرا ما هو سببه
اولا معنويات مرتفعه لدى العناصر وخليط من
الاسلحه الغربيه ثلاثه من هذه الاسلحه
غيرت مسار الحرب وفقا لتقييم خبراء
عسكريين غربيين وسنتابع سويا ما هي اولها
صواريخ جافلون الامريكيه المضاده للمدرعات
وهي ايضا هذه الجافلين هي منخفضه التكلفه
تسمى بالرمح هي سهله الاستخدام ليلا
ونهارا وتصيب الهدف بسهوله مداه الاقصى
يبلغ
4,750 مترا كما نتابع هنا الصمود
الاوكرانيه ساهمت به ايضا منظومه
المدفعيه وهي عاليه الحركه حيث نتابع هنا
صوره لها هي راجمه صواريخ متعدده منصوبه
على مدرعات خفيفه هذه الراجمه ما هو
خمسه اطنان بامكانها اطلاق ست صواريخ في
الوقت نفسه يتم توجيهها بواسطه نظام تحديد
المواقع الجغرافي ويبلغ مداها نحو 80 كيلو
مترا كما نتابع قاذفه هاي سهله التنقل
والحركه ايضا بحيث تطيح للقوات اصابه
الهدف في وقت قياسي والتحرك بعيدا لتجنب
هجمات مضاده كما ساهمت ب 70% من التقدم
العسكري على جبهه خيرسون بحسب قاده
اوكرانيين ما هو السلاح الثالث الذي بنيت
عليه مقدرات الهجوم الاوكراني هي طائرات
بيرقدار وهي طائرات بين اقطار تحديدا تي
بي 2 وهي مسيرات خفيفه الوزن هي اقل
بحوالي سبع مرات من طائره ريبر الامريكيه
طول جناحيها يبلغ اثني عشر مترا ما يسمح
لها
بالبقاء في السماء لمده تصل الى 30 ساعه
في الطلعه الواحده هذه الطائرات اثبتت
فعاليتها في اصابه الاهداف حيث يمكن لكل
طائره منها ان تحمل اربعه صواريخ كما
نتابع موجه بالليزر طبعا من ميزاتها ايضا
القدره على تجميعها من قطع جاهزه
[موسيقى]